Hello everybody my name is Markiplier!
And welcome to "Captured" now- (creepy music starts)
*hahohahohahoahahoHA* (singing)
HI!
WHO DA HELL ARE YOU SIRBEDLAM-oh fff (squeaking creatures)
*creeeek*
OKHAY
AH
I just got in this..
Oh this oh this is the menu
OH SHIT
I-it was a start butt-
Okay, alright
I-you know what I'm not gonna go back
We're just gonna plow right through
Hi! How's it goin?
My name is Markiplier
and here we're gonna play a horror game by the name of "Captured"
That's supposed to be
Pretty dang scary
and
(Erie heart beating sound)
right now we'r....
ohh geezz
oh god
ookay I'm gonna make some predictions
were waking up on an operating table
we have no memory of who we are!!!
ohh geeze
oh my GHHAAAD
this is legit
uueelch
Hiiiii
Helloooo
I probably shouldn't SHOUT
oh GEEZE
oh my....
(Creepy intercom voice) "WELCOME VISITOR"
"YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING WHERE YOU ARE"
Lil' bit...
"YOU ARE UNDERGROUND"
"YOU HAVE FALLEN INTO A HOLE"
"AND ARE NO LONGER IN THE FOREST OVERHEAD"
"YOU ARE NOW AT THE START OF A SERIES OF CHAMBERS"
"DOWN HERE, WE'RE GOING TO PLAY A LITTLE GAME..."
"IN ORDER TO ESCAPE EACH CHAMBER, AND PROGRESS TO THE NEXT,"
"YOU MUST LOCATE EACH CHAMBER'S ACTIVATION LEVER"
"SOMEWHERE NEARBY.."
*chair breaks* "IT WILL BECOME INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO FIND-
*Mark whisper yelling* SORRY!
"-EACH LEVER..."
"... AS WELL AS ESCAPE UNHARMED."
"YOU SEE...
"YOU ARE NOT ALONE DOWN HERE"
"THERE IS A MAN WHO WISHES TO CUT YOU UP AND EAT YOU"
Mark: WHY!?
*intercom voice* "HIS NAME IS DAMION CLYDE"
"AND HE IS BLIND"
"BUT, HE LISTENS"
"SO BE QUIET, VISITOR"
"BE VERY VERY QUIET" (we all know he'll scream his way through this)
*terrified* Ookay!
*creepy voice again* "GO AHEAD, FIND THE LEVER"
"MY VOICE IS WAITING..."
*Mark* hA-KAY, THANK YOUU
I'LL BE ON THE LOOKOUT FOR DAMION CLYDE
WHO WANTS TO CUT ME UP AND EAT ME...
WHY DOES HE WANT TO EAT ME!?
I don't knuh-what happened?
I was-what, I was in the forest
What, I was goin' for a jog
And I fell in a hole and I ended up on a bloody bed?
I'm sorry, I-I need to take a minute
To-oh my god
Because, I was tossed in here
In the most literal sense of the word,
And now I need to find a lever
To escape a man by the name of Damion Clyde
..Who wants to eat me, okay...
*bottle clanks* Fuck, and I need to not make noise
'Cause he is blind, and can only hear me, s-
*LOUDER CLANKING OF SAID BOTTLES*
Oh my fucking god
I'm gonna die so hard!
AH GEEZE
Okay, alrighty then, alright
IMMNA, IMMNA EXPONGE, THE BITCHEST NATURE
OUT OF MY BODY,
GO INTO BADMA.. BADMASS MODE
BADASS, MARKIPLIER MODE
ALSO KNOWN AS
BADMASS MODE
And find a fuckin' lever
Jesus...
*LOUD BREAKING OF CHAIR*
God dammit, is it the toilet?
Whazat mean?
Of all places there'd be a toilet in here
*under his breath* Jesus
Oh, here we go *MINOR JUMPSCARE ALERT*
*RANDOM SCREAMING*
AH I'M SORREH 'BOUT THAT
DIDN'T MEAN TO OPEN UP YOUR PRIVATE COLLECTION THERE
Okay?
So what do I, what the fuck do I do?
Can I open that again? (fetish much? XD)
Jus a lil' bit? Can I get a sneak peek of it?
*MINOR JUMPSCARE IN TWO SECONDS*
*DOOR THUMPIN'* WOAH HEY, OKAY
DID I DO THAT? I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING
Was there a lever there?
I CAAN'T SEE
I can't see a fuckin' thing toni-okay
Alrighty then, alright!
Trusting the uh...
Ominous dark hallway I'm sure this is gonna, oh shit
Why.. Okay, y'know what, hang on
I just- fuckin' hell
I'm havin' a bit of an adjustment issue
I literally, sprinted into this game *minor jumpscare in five*
And I have no idea what's going on
*DOOR CRASH* FUCKING HELL
*intercom voice again* "WELL DONE, VISITOR"
"YOU'VE PROBABLY NOTICED BY NOW THAT YOU'RE BAREFOOT"
"THIS IS TO BALANCE THE GAME IN YOUR FAVOR"
Mark: Okay...
"IT'S ONLY FAIR DON'T YOU THINK?"
Mark: No..
"OH, AND...I'D LIKE TO APOLOGIZE"
"FOR THE SURPRISE NEEDLE TO THE NECK."
Mark: Ohh... "IT WAS ONLY A HARMLESS SEDATIVE, SO DON'T WORRY."
"ANYWAY, NOW THAT YOU KNOW HOW THESE CHAMBERS WORK..."
"... ALLOW ME TO INTRODUCE YOU..."
"...TO THE OTHER ELEMENT OF THE GAME."
Mark: Nope, no thank you
"MEET... DAMION CLYDE."
Mark: OHHEY!!!
Mark: I THOUGHT YOU WERE GONNA COME A-
Mark: IDIDN'T KNOWTHERE WAS A DOOR OVER THERE!
Mark: I'M SORRY... Ohhh God... Ohhh geez... Okay...
If I don't move he can't hear me, right?!
Ohhh... hi. Oho god don't look at me like that!
You don't... you don't want none of THIS
*karate chop*
I've got *two finger NOPE* imPENETRABLE DEF- oh okay
I'm gonna put away
*smooch smooch*
I'm gonna put these away
what the fuck do I- I probably have to
throw something to dis- *hears approaching*
*high pitch scream attack GO!*
OHF*CK DUDE that didn't go anywhere !
I am super wimpy!
Ahhh Jesus... ok you can't hear me.
The slip-slap on my barefoots don't pay any mind to him
Ohh what is that- OH it's a skull! Oh God!
It's a skull and a tongue. Oh God. What do I do?!
OH HI!
Oh Jesus... ok? alright? Oh hey how's it going?
*flips lever in noisiest fashion*
AAAAAAAHHHHH!
OKAY! ALL RIGHT THEN!
OKAY! ALL RIGHT! OH THERE'S A DOOR NOW! OKAY! ALL RIGHT! BYEEEEE!!!
F*CKING F******CK...
*intercom* "NICE WORK, VISITOR"
Mark: Thanks
"HERE IN THIS CHAMBER, THERE ARE 2 LEVERS"
"ONE CONTROLS BOTH GATES..."
"... AND THE OTHER CONTROLS ONE GATE
BUT ALSO THE EXIT."
*Marki-moan*
"THIS IS SIMPLY PRACTICE. BUT DON'T FORGET..."
"... BE AS QUIET AS YOU CAN."
Mark: ... Okay, THANK YOU... for the constant reminder
that death is looming around the corner
okay so this two levers... one opens both gates...
... one opens gate and exit so I need to find 2 and not get the wrong o-
... why is there...
why is there a little toy...
Why? Why?! Why is there a seesaw horse and
a beer bottle?!
I'm trying to understand the
conjunctions here between these two
dissing and d-d bfurrnumbrrr...
items
whatever the word was. ok. so there's one
lever here... and one lever in there.
AND A LOT OF BLOOD ON THAT LEVER
W-which I don't know why there's THAT much blood...
I don't have no I have no I ok alright
*NOISY LEVER FLIP AND GATE SLAM*
Oh hi buddy... you can't hear me, do ya?
Eeeeeeehhhhh
Eehhhh...
slip - slap - slippity slap
sloop - slap - slip - slap -oh f*ckin you...
Oh hey Clyde. Hey Damien Clyde. DC.
Do you mind if I call you... "Dick Cock"?
I don't know... ok alright...
Gonna go for this one now~
In the room of bloo-od... Oh god...
*FLIPS*
OH HE DIDN'T LIKE THAT!
Oh. Okay. All ri-AAAAAAAAAAHHHH!!!
*Marki-moans* -kay, I duked ya!
Okay -AAAHHHH!
*intercom* "PEOPLE CAN BE SO CRUEL."
"LOOKING DOWN THEIR NOSES AT OTHERS..."
"... JUDGING THEM."
"WE'RE A CORRUPT SPECIES. DAMIEN KNOWS THIS ALL TOO WELL."
"EVEN THE BUILDERS WHO CONSTRUCTED THESE CHAMBERS..."
"... THIS SYSTEM... SHOWED CONTEMPT."
"THEY DIDN'T LIKE HIS APPEARANCE... HIS DEMEANOR..."
"THEY WERE ONLY HERE TO HURRY AND FINISH THE JOB..."
"... AND RECEIVE THEIR PAYMENT AND GET THE HELL OUT."
"PEOPLE ARE GREEDY... GREEDY LITTLE TWATS..."
Mark: Are they?
"BUT DOWN HERE, DAMIEN WILL FINALLY HAVE HIS TURN..."
"MAYBE OUR OTHER VISITOR HERE HAS OVERHEARD US."
"YESSS... LET'S ADD SOME MORE FUN TO THIS GAME."
Mark: Okay-oh Jesus.
"HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF THE 'HEAD CRUSHER'?"
Mark: No... D:
"IT WAS A TORTURE DEVICE FIRST RECORDED IN THE 1500s..."
"GO AHEAD, TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT ITS DESIGN."
Mark: Hi...
"AS THE NAME SUGGESTS, AND AS YOU CAN PROBABLY TELL BY LOOKING AT IT..."
"... THIS DEVICE SIMPLY CRUSHES THE HEAD OF ITS VICTIM."
"NOW... IN ORDER TO ESCAPE THIS CHAMBER..."
"THE HEAD CRUSHER WILL NEED TO BE ACTIVATED, BY FLIPPING THE SWITCH NEXT TO IT."
"AND IT SEPARATING YOU FROM THE LEVER ACTIVATING THE EXIT..."
"... WILL OPEN. AND, THE HEAD CRUSHER WILL BEGIN TO LOWER ITSELF IN SMALL INCREMENTS."
"NOW VISITOR... HERE'S WHERE YOU HAVE A CHOICE."
"IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SAVE THIS POOR HELPLESS PERSON... YOU CAN."
"BUT IN ORDER TO DO SO, YOU WILL NEED TO TURN
EACH OF THE THREE WHEELS IN THIS ROOM
UNTIL THEIR CORRESPONDING CIRCUITS HAVE BEEN CONNECTED."
"BUT..."
"YOU WILL NEED TO ACTIVATE THESE CIRCUITS WITH YOUR NEW FRIEND DAMIEN IN THE ROOM."
Mark: whyyyy?
"AND TRUST ME, THOSE WHEELS ARE VERY SQUEAKY~"
Mark: "Squeaky~"
"OR, YOU CAN SIMPLY RAISE THE LEVER"
"TO OPEN THE EXIT. AT WHICH POINT  THE HEAD CRUSHER..."
"... WILL BE ACTIVATED ALL THE WAY. AND THIS POOR HELPLESS PERSON WILL NO LONGER BE WITH US."
"IT'S YOUR CHOICE, VISITOR. IT'S YOUR CHOICE."
Mark: Oh, why is it MY choice?!
WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE MY CHOICE?! Of COURSE I wanna SAVE them!
I just have a funny feeling I'm not
gonna be ABLE to if Damien Clyde is in the room with me!
All right anyway alright don't worry bucko
i'm gonna call you Smith Aroon or
because you're about to be blown to that
but either way I'm gonna try my best to
save you your head no gonna be crushed
don't you worry about a little ol' baby thing
so we got three wheels *knocks over bottle*
shit I need to NOT do that
He-eh~ *bottle smash*
I probably should have saved that.
Ah yes, I'm an idiot so... there's a lever in there
and a lever in there, I'm assuming
that THAT lever that I'm looking at
right now is going to start this whole
endeavor and not just straight-up kill him
so let's try this *flip lever* oh. OH HI!
Hi... okay...
Don't mind me... just gonna... oh geez... oh God... oh
I need to hurry
oh I need to hurry okay. all right I get it
hAAAAAAHHH! hAAAAAAAAHHH!
OHGOD
OW! OWIE! HOW AM I - OH F*CKIN HELL
eeaaaAAAAAAA
oh Jesus... okay I'm
I- there's no fucking way
he's not gonna let me go! AAAAH!
ah fucking Jesus I can't do this how the
fuck are you able to do this?!
Oh God I'm SORRY! OH GEEZ! OH GOD! I'M SORRY!
IT WASN'T ME, IT WASN'T ME- oh god he's like- AAAAHH! F*CKIN F*CK!
How the f- I CAN'T! Wha- it's not f*ckin POSSIBLE!
*ALARM, HORRID HEAD CRUSHING AND SCREAMING*
*horrifying screams and voices*
*sounds of a woman screaming*
*Marki-noises of guilt and horror* ooooooKAAAAAAY...
I'M SOOORYYYYY
WHAT COULD I HAVE DOOOONE?!
WHAT COULD I HAVE DONE, I COULD'VE DONE NOTHING!
THERE WAS NOTHING I COULD DOOOO!
HE WAS FU- Are you kidding me?! That was imPOSSIBLE!
How in the F*CK? D:
I mean it's like I said I didn't think there
was gonna be a way to actually do it
there's no way- oh geez what is thiiiis?
ohhhh god... what is this?!
"It's not exactly the best, there's only one tiny tube of
antibiotic and two bandages... heals one hit."
okay... great.
oh goody... oh goody goody gumdrops what
the fuck is this shit...
Is there another lever in here?
Is there something by the dead bodies?
Does this mean something, is this a pattern?
I'm guessing... i gotta hit the
buttons in a pattern...poink ok. poink
poink poink poink poink poink poink
I'm a smart cookie I'm very smart i know i'm a
very smart guy
alright sees it didn't even give me like
a tutorial on this bullshit of a fucking
wheel like look at this shit
where am I supposed to turn this
bullshit down and oh I'm supposed to go
down and then around
*squeaky turning*
... ughhhh... the-THIS?! what IS this?!
WHAT?!
*alarm noises*
Th-THERE'S NO WAY! If I had to turn it THAT much
the WHOLE time
there's no freaking way that would have
EVER worked for three of them no way he
was
there's no way to save him. it was just a
matter of if you wanted to pull the
lever and then get I don't like- *slamming noise*
the fuck is that?
... ok
I don't know what this is... oh geez
I don't like this... all these mannequins in this room
My mannequin d-
OHFUCKYOU
HI. HOW YOU DOIN? HI. HI FRIEND!
Are you Clyde? is that you Damien?
ok...so gotta start from here go around
oh hey hey buddy how you doing oh this
is not fun place to be
oh hey you look like you got arms oh
geez
so if i'm not mistaken i gotta push the
buttons in order
ok...boop
ok...
boop...
boop...ok alright, this is, this is wierd
oh this was the last one...boop
no, is that not right?
did I not do dat right?
ok so it must be the number of white
things on there i believe this is the
first one even though it's at the end of
the arrow because it's the shortest and
there's one two three four..maybe five
but i'm going to assume not five and
then assume that for that one so one two
three four cuz there's a chair hidden
back there in 12345678 and
one
there's five bodies so 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12, is that makes sense?
god damn it you can only go up to 11 so
one of these things is not like the other
...3,4,5...
...2,3,4,5,6,7...
oh!
I don't know what I did
I did 5, 7 and 11
which I suppesed is good?
ominous music isn't good
fuck this thing
*jumpscare incoming*
FUCK YOU! holy fucken shiat!
HI! ah fuck.
ohh how am I supposed to be able to do this!
Ah fuck youu!!
AaaAahh
oh fuck I can't jump
Aahhhh!!
fucking fuck fuck fuck
gimme that...
gimme this x7
habusci (?)
ok...
*Mark screaming*
fucking fuck
Jesus Christ...ok so I got through that-
YEAH! I guess, oh mah god ok that was like
the last part was mostly like guesswork
because i didn't know exactly what I was
supposed to be doing but it still was
not bad at all that was that wasn't not
bad
that was good that was legitimately good
this is the start of something good it
had good graphics it had good ambience it
had good atmosphere animations are good
villain good challenge to the gameplay
of it
good moral choices that were so conflicting
I don't know if I could ever
be able to save that dude unless I was
whipping my arm around the wheel as
fast as I could but maybe you guys can
do that yourselves. I'll put a link to the game
down in the description below and thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought of this down there
in the comments because holy shit this
was good so thanks again and as always I
will see you
in the next video
Bye bye!! :D
*damn cool outro right?*
*dah dunn da dunn*
bye :D